kathy was so funny last season where the
heck is kathy and why did she get locked
out of the store like
okay i saw that on the um i saw that in
the trailer because i wasn't in before i
was somewhere else so when i saw that i
felt so bad and she called me after
and she was like and she goes i didn't
know she didn't know they locked her out
so they
didn't realize that i was like oh my god
i didn't know i would have opened the
door had i been in the store um i know
but she was she couldn't film in the
beginning because she was dealing with
the wedding and when i tell you like it
wasn't just a regular wedding it was
like it wasn't like what color flowers
it was a multi-day multi-experienced
wedding yeah and then they were also
filming her other show um paris's show
so i think she decided like i couldn't
she couldn't give everything you know
yeah but she comes back when the
wedding's over
oh good we love to hear it we love to
hear it i know that we have a new
housewife diana and you guys seem to be
getting along cool um how do you think
diana will do with this group of women
she it's funny i
i don't think i was well i don't even
think i was well received this year as
much as she was her first year
um with the group
she walked in and everyone kind of like
loved her not everybody
many were
um
welcoming and love her and i've known
her for maybe
five or six years yeah and um
i
knew she would be kind of polarizing
um
but she and i got really close over the
season she's a really good person and
i hope we get to see that side of her
she can be tough though she's really
like she doesn't hold back so
um i know that you and sutton have had
like a roller coaster friendship what is
the status of your friendship with
sutton now
yeah i mean i think people can see you
know online because you know what
happened with with this season were at
about november last year
and so we're in june now and yes i think
there's context to that
and sutton and i spent a lot of time
together we probably text at least a few
times a week
get together at least once every two
weeks we're together quite often and i'm
really happy i feel like we went through
a lot we were
against each other
we were on the same side against other
people at some point and you know as
painful as that is it actually helps you
grow as friends
because you really learn about how you
know every it's not surface anymore
whereas most relationships you find our
surface um we have to dig deep sometimes
and painful sometimes but um we get to
the other end and it's been really nice
yeah what's going on with the leather
pants
where are they they're in my closet and
fabulous then i bring them out as much
as i can i loved those leather pants
just so that worked
[Laughter]
um what was your reaction watching the
most recent episode the crystal conum
drunks i know
for me watching it between dorit kyle
garcelle i feel like they were getting
at you from like multiple angles so i
just was like how did she feel watching
that back yeah um i've been to be really
honest i've been nervous about watching
it and
i have to say i feel
relieved watching it i was not sure
if people
would see it
uh differently how it actually happened
but i think people really saw what
happened yeah and that's all it is like
no one's perfect and certainly i'm not
but i could live with myself i can go to
bed well if i
if the truth is out so i do feel like
people saw sort of what was happening to
me and it doesn't end
for a while but it is what it is and you
know when you're new it's you know it's
a little bit easier
for
people to sort of they know when they
don't know you and so
maybe this is their way of getting to
know people it's not my way but
it's their way but yeah it was hard and
also
weirdly
a relief
yeah
in the trailer we see you and erica
having a bit of an argument um how has
the rest of the season been for you thus
far
um
i i would definitely say this what
happened yesterday
yesterday's episode was one of the most
challenging experiences i had on the
show i certainly get into some things
with other people
um with erica you know that was also
quite challenging to talk about her
situation
um but i as i because i got through what
happened
you know these upcoming weeks
um i felt even more comfortable speaking
up and sort of saying my piece and my
perspective
and you know you go home like last year
i was so scared i'm like what is what
are people gonna think about it and this
year it's like i don't really care
because i know where i stand on things
and
i do feel like i'm standing on the right
side
yeah
i love this for you okay yes i love to
hear all of this
so
in the season premiere we we see into
what happened with dorit and her home
invasion
for you just as a wife and a mother what
was your feeling when you were watching
that emotional scene with pk reuniting
with your reed at kyle's house
uh rob and i watched together and we
were crying and it makes me emotional
thinking about and i i texted duriet
right away and rob texted pk and just
said you know like
watching your experience i mean i
already felt it when i heard about it
obviously but i just said you know
how incredibly strong she was and how
strong she is today because i know their
family differently you know our kids
play together
and
um of course you can't help but put
yourself in someone's shoes
so to see them experience that and the
effects that will always be with them is
so hard but you know she was she saved
her kids lives she did
and
you know
whatever
whatever said you know i think he felt
so guilty and we always say like if you
were there maybe it would have been
something different
you just don't know but the outcome
thank god was that they all came out
safe and that's ultimately what we care
about um but it was hard to watch and
it's hard as a parent you know her kids
are exact same age as mine
and once that happened we as a group we
we really stepped up our security
your reaction was what i think
everyone's reaction was like emotional
and just feeling for to read um what was
your reaction watching
sutton
handle that conversation with kyle did
you feel like she was dismissive by the
way that you're the first person to ask
me that question and i've thought about
that over and over again because you
know i i obviously was very upset with
the group
um
and i defended her because i thought
that they were not giving her the
benefit out i didn't like it
that's the part of it i didn't like it
um
i still believe that
uh
but i believe in her the reasons why she
reacted that too
so you know you have to go through those
moments right in the moment i was like
why is she acting like that and then she
explained it to me because i got to talk
to her privately about it and so i'm
like i get your experience like i don't
have that so i'm not going to react that
way i don't have a fear of the same
fears that you have
so i that's why my heart is open to that
but you when you first watch the
reaction that's why i'm like but if she
reacted that
that way to me i would have said why are
you reacting this way not you shouldn't
want that way right
between myself and some of the people on
the show and i would try to get to the
bottom of it without calling someone out
without
um
like
without judging them i i
always try to look at as to why people
do things the way they do it
yeah that is like really embedded in
your value system and that's one thing
that i've noticed is that you really
you want to get to the why and
understanding people and why they do
things as opposed to judging why they do
it and i know you've been hitting that
home throughout the season so thank you
for saying that and seeing that and
that's really where i'm coming from yes
no one has the same history and jeff my
brother jeff and i always say like we
grew up in the same house we have the
same parents we're a year and a half
apart but our experience of life is
still different
and we should not be
looked at as one homogenized unit we are
all different and we all have different
ways of handling things and but thank
you for saying that
no absolutely i i can't imagine the
highs and lows of filming
what do you do to decompress when you
get home like how are you feeling
emotionally after a day
of filming when when oftentimes people
are arguing
yeah it's really hard well last my first
season it was you know in the peak of
covid so you go home to a very quiet
home i mean my house has my kids but
it's still very lonely and quiet
whereas this time i could go back and
have my life so especially when i had a
driver
um if they're usually if there's any
alcohol they have car services right and
um i'd always take advantage and i would
say take me straight to the play date
and then i would go hang out with my
friends
and i would say i hang out with the same
group of my friends and the kids at
least three days four day three four
days a week and i go and we play mahjong
the kids play outside i just go deep
back into my normal life yeah because
i'm like this i cannot go to bed
remembering this stuff anymore i have to
like have my normal life and then i go
to school pick up or you know yeah
that's how i decompress is because it
makes me more grateful about my life you
know like i didn't appreciate as much
until you hang out with these people
you